good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the final routine cabinet of the
municipal year although we do have an
extra meeting on the 23rd to look at
papers to go to council the following
day and that's about a formation of a
housing company and we've also got we've
also got that day warming Tain's a
parish plan council kettle can join us
at the main table if you're substituting
for the chairman you can you know write
item one apologies for absence apologies
we see from Council Orton and some
counts for Atkinson and councillor
Rich's was last heard of in his car
talking to us on his way
eta five past - according to his sat-nav
what did I say in Rich's sorry I don't
see y'all here Dave
I'm sure he winds me up right to
disclosure of interest on anything on
the agenda none right the minutes of the
meeting on the 12th of March are there I
might add that we did have a request
from the speaker at Studley for a slight
modification to the minutes we decided
against making that modification on the
grounds that the mill is very good and
that's if you agree to it and also we
had a situation whereby the points that
they wanted including were included in
an assurance and councillor Rich's
I did say Richards that time yeah that
he gave to the meeting that the
effectively everything was on course and
I've since had a feedback from him and
from the co-op in steadily that the
actions that were promised by them have
effectively been taking place so do we
agree the cabinet minutes of the 12th of
March yeah agreed thank you
item four snitterfield Neighborhood
Development plan we've been circulated a
copy of the referendum version of
snitterfield Neighborhood Development
Plan because we've gone through all the
earlier stages for this particular
document and the effectively it went to
referendum and as such somewhere it'll
tell us just how far
three-one yes ninety four point two
eight percent yes vote that's three
hundred and thirty yes votes in
centerfield 220 no votes and as such
that makes it worthy of adoption fact I
don't think we have any real alternative
and I don't think we would want any real
alternative because this is a good
neighborhood development plan they
worked hard at it they've gone through
all the stages and therefore to adopt it
though requires a decision of four
council so the recommendation to us
today on page eleven is the set of your
neighborhood development plan is adopted
with the immediate effect or it will be
on the 24th of April
with the consequence it becomes part of
the development plan any discussion
councilor rich is only a very quick wind
chair though we normally congratulate
them at the end of this process because
this is now forms part of the
development strategy doesn't it so I've
just got a funny feeling from memory we
normally so you want us to add onto the
recommendation that we congratulate the
steering group and the parish certainly
revenue as the hardware that's gone in
right so the recommendation is being
modified by that if you agree so is that
agreed agreed right I will quickly move
on funding of corporate priorities this
is something which we all did discuss
informally with each other and as a
result mr. Buckland has produced a paper
as we keep being reminded by councillor
Morse we're awash with cash we have a
lot of issues that come up and a lot of
issues about what to do with the spare
cash and effectively there's been a
number of suggestions but this paper
contains a list of proposals one off
spending that we propose and there is
also a reserve list in paragraph one ten
of other things that we could do some
work on but we're not proposing any
particular funding for this so
consequently we might add that some
things are conditional for example
Ulster Greg Center as you will know that
we have effectively given Ulster Greg
sends a notice that we are discontinuing
the leisure agreement with them we plan
all things being equal to run it
ourselves and the reason that we
put the extra funding in for the Greg
Center it's quite simple the original
agreement for a managed transfer was
three years ago we put a budget in place
at that time and of course the buildings
have deteriorated while they've
continued to be run by the trust and
we're not aware that any money's been
put in and I'm staring at a couple of
ulster members that are confirming that
that's a correct statement I'm be amazed
if they didn't and indeed so therefore
we've decided that if we if and when we
do take it over in July we will need
some additional funding to bring the
leisure center lifestyles facility up to
scratch so it can be added to the list
of things that are run by everybody
active or SLM as we often affectionately
knew it as so consequently we want that
process to be as smooth as possible we
inevitably realize that some work to be
done so we're getting the budget in for
it fairly soon so again these budgets
have to be approved by for council it is
not a cabinet decision the issue is this
the broadband for example I think I
ought to mention because that's on top
of the budget provision we've already
put in the broadband when we decided in
the closing days of the budget process
that that nice mr. javi had given us an
extra sixty thousand pounds as part of
our budget settlement we decided that we
would effectively do some enabling work
with much of that money and but this is
for initiative to go far more widely
across the district because
interestingly enough I got into trouble
so I went to a conference about a month
ago and speaking at this conference was
the was Margo James MP who's the
minister in DCMS for broadband and she
stood up in front of the whole assembled
audience
and said shouldn't we give ourselves a
pat on the back now the whole of England
is on 95% coverage now I've been to a
presentation of the scrutiny committee
not that long beforehand and effectively
had been told by John Parmenter a
Warwickshire County Council but in fact
it was considerably less than that
Margot said I don't believe your figures
I'm gonna check them out however there's
been another meeting of the scrutiny
committee since then which have got some
statistics into it in one of the reports
or one of the appendices to the previous
minutes and I calculated that we were as
low as 66% you looked at me counselor
kettle as if you are going to put your
mental arithmetic against me and
challenge me on those figures well aware
of the good work of both of you in this
area and effectively I'm hoping I'm
quoting you accurately
however I've now written to Margo James
with the figures and statistics that
were in the scrutiny committee midis
said this has been published by my
council would you like to challenge it
and I've had no reply so anyway however
I don't think she's languishing in the
thought that we were no 95% like certain
parts of the country so anyway I'll come
to you in a minute council kettle the
issue is that effectively we've got some
money in there to make a big difference
to broadband provision in some of our
areas and I could list many of them and
we can debate them if you wish however
but that's just a couple of things these
are important things to do with the
spare money we didn't feel that we were
sufficiently well prepared to actually
do it as part of the budget statement to
council so I make no apologies for that
but effectively I brought
propose along as soon as we can once our
budgets been settled right counselor
riches would like to speak and counselor
kettle I'll take them in that order
no thank you chair and counselor moss so
as most of you already know I've got to
sort of pet projects in this list that
I've feel really strongly about but I
would be looking for a slight adjustment
in so much that if we talk about rural
broadband first of all you might recall
last week that was that was on the front
page of The Herald it was well
represented as to what I'd said it's
been slightly misinterpreted in the
public domain and I think where the
confusion is coming in is the actual
labeling of the home in The Herald for
getting it wrong I don't know it was it
was very well represented in the
heralding which is limited I noticed in
the public domain I think the reason for
that is the reason for that is the
corporate priority title is rural
broadband and but I think we should
probably clarify that that is about
wireless rural broadband rather than
we're not going to be running in fiber
pipes or copper lines we're looking at
innovative ways of delivering wireless
broadband to the extremities of the
district the rural areas that probably
will not get high-speed broadband via a
cable or a a fiber line so I guess I
would like to change the title of that
to wireless broadband if we can because
I think that's more that the crux of it
is about new technology and and reaches
those extremities so I'm really excited
about that because I think will cover an
awful lot of distance with that and I
think will be very very effective
Wireless goes a long way covers an awful
lot of areas very very quickly and it is
about looking forward to the future and
the second part that I'm really keen on
is the business center slash workshop I
don't think that's as descriptors it
could be but I don't think there's any
other option and this is about trying to
provide specific types of accommodation
that we've got evidence to support
businesses don't have accomodation in
Coventry for example where we could
potentially provide suitable
accommodation inside Stratford district
that's that's a real big thumbs up as
far as I'm concerned we use venture
as a blueprint for those things but that
doesn't necessarily mean that we clone
venture house we use it as an
informative exercise a prototype an
exercise to deliver the next wave of
business development units so I'm really
keen for both of those but yeah I guess
I would like rural broadband to yeah be
a little bit further I don't want the
public thinking that we're gonna start
digging up roads and putting in fiber
lines because that's a 500 grand doesn't
go very far doing that and being that's
not not what we're trying to achieve you
know we haven't got a full development
brief here I don't think he's probably I
don't think we need to be shy about this
but we are looking for premises in
Studley in Southam and one or two other
places as well in order to try and use
the venture house model as a an example
of where we're going
learn perhaps from some of the mistakes
and some of the difficulties we've had
with it but equally well put forward a
reliable facility that's different to
venture house in the in those
communities casa kettle thank thank you
mr. chairman
finally on what rural broadband yes the
future is clearly wireless rather than
wired I do know that mr. Buckland has or
should have met by now I believe a
wireless provider who approached a
resident in my ward and I attended that
presentation what they made quite clear
was their business model does not
require third-party funding in order to
deliver the services across the rural
broadband they've carried out a project
in rural Wales whereby the methodology
which works has been done with with no
state input so therefore firstly I would
support cancer Rich's in that any
funding that goes towards this
I'm slightly more specifically must be
must not be limit must not be sent off
to the current Covent Biddy UK Coventry
solid home workshop scheme because we in
the overview description company have
repeatedly tried to get information
about their level of coverage and we
have I have to say I hopefully my
countless loved colleagues will agree
with me found it like trying to push
water uphill
the level of detail the level of
knowledge relating to roll out and
Stratford I have to say is shockingly
low therefore if we're going to put
budget 1/2 million pounds in I would be
really upset until the level of
accountability that what you see from
Beadie UK is improved dramatically that
that money is retained for use elsewhere
if we can get wireless broadband from
existing market suppliers at limited
cost then it may not MIT we may not even
require this half million pound
provision and so I'm just slightly
worried that you know what I don't see
is we don't need it for wireless BT UK
come back to us and they turn around and
say well we've got a budget for it well
let's give it to them and see that they
can improve it what their current status
is they told us they will achieve ninety
five and a half percent which is the
minimum required by your Minister but we
are about 90 percent at the moment and
if you look at the statistics they
provided which purportedly purportedly
underpin their delivery it would seem
there is about 8% of houses which they
confirm they can't get to or don't even
know where those houses are so if
they're going to hit four and a half
percent by the end of next year and they
don't even know where those houses are
it seems to me there might be
contradiction terms between what they're
putting down in what hard data we have
got and the headline news they delivered
that's
that's my point of broadband mr. shim
okay councillor Morse
we could move it on from broadband
chairman I don't disagree with any of
the items on the list I'm sure they're
all worthy projects but it does more the
smack could be a list of pet projects of
various cabinet members I'm somewhat
disappointed what projects they had in
mind in fact we will help to remedy that
show by putting forward a motion a
pencil with five ideas over own but I
think all council members should be
approached to see if they've got any
worthwhile schemes also surprise
chairman we've got a list there with
money attached to them with no business
cases as far as I can see but then some
other projects where we're talking about
building up a business case I would have
thought before putting any specific
amounts of any of them a business case
ought to be developed and I think
councillor kettle is well illustrate at
this point by saying we've put 500
billion aside for broadband is that the
correct amount we've no idea whether
that's the correct amount cheville we
don't know what it will pay for we don't
know what he will we need a business
case I would have no trouble whatsoever
we're saying we think we've got surplus
funds of two and a half million let's
see what the most worthwhile schemes are
huh that would make sense but to do it
like this chair the list with fairly
arbitrary sounds doesn't seem to me the
best way of going about it
equally chairman I'm sure government
grants are available to support some of
these items they must be we know fair
one for example on charging charging
vehicles which I'm sure is down there
somewhere we can get government grants
the peer-review it's about using money
to drive future income there's no
mention in here of what revenue streams
could arise from any of these items I
can well see study there's a SATA
generating in more detail we meet the
cast of it more widely and more work
needs to be done in presenting business
everything that comes forward doing
money right councillor riches thanks
Jeff
so first of all just quickly going back
to broadband I know you wanted to move
on from that leader very quickly going
back to that for clarity this is not a
joint initiative with the County Council
or Biddy you go ready to know that this
is a Stratford initiative and and I
think that's quite that's really
important that it's an innovation from
here from this building not any sort of
joint project I wouldn't want to see any
of that money disappear off towards
Biddy UK or or anything in terms of
members ideas because I guess it could
be interpreted that there are some pet
projects there I'm not sure it's for
sure is it's this pet project so much as
everybody attaches themselves to
something I'm sure Peter you'll find
something in that list that you think is
a good idea that you would attach
yourself to they're all good young it's
particularly the business center and
broadband I do attach myself to those
because I think they're really good
ideas so I think the doors are always
open from the cabinet's perspective for
members to come forward with ideas
I think the cabinet makes strategic
decisions about money as is as is it as
is its gift and I don't ever remember a
situation where members are the members
wouldn't be allowed to come and flow
ideas I think that's a really good idea
in fact in terms of revenue I agree with
steadily but I disagree that that you
don't see any
revenue from any of the other ideas no
you may not see it revenue from the
earlier days I see revenue from some of
the other ideas I see revenue from the
business center slash workshops there is
revenue generated by venture house rural
broadband there could well be a revenue
model for that I agree there isn't a
specific business case but there could
well be a revenue model for the council
from that support for Culture and
Tourism that's already 250 million pound
a year there are there abouts there's
revenue to be generated from that so I
think all of these things are innovative
and add value to the taxpayer I don't
think it's a case that we're just
desperately trying to spend money I
think it's a case that we're looking at
innovative ways of generating revenue
and growth for the authority without
compromising services right now so
Cargill
I've got you Morris thank you very much
an interesting debate there are some
elements of the the blisters can put
forward which probably on the face of it
won't stand up to a business case and
won't necessarily be seen to be
generating money as an income straight
away like for example a hostile homeless
study but we have to have these things
there isn't a thing on this list that I
don't disagree with I think they're all
very valuable worthwhile projects saying
I've been banging on about broadband
again is if we wait for broadband view
game to come and come and do it he'll be
years along we can't afford to wait for
our some of our rural communities who
desperately need broadband now the rural
business is that we're trying to
encourage as part and parcel of our
policies in this council we've got to do
that and if it means we put the money up
then so be it as far as I'm concerned in
that particular case also I am concerned
sometimes if we do start putting
business cases first and then wait and
wait and wait for those to happen these
things could it could go into the next
year another year we need to kick-start
some of these things now I appreciate
that we have to have a business case but
some of these have already been a long
long time coming we're talking about pet
projects well the Greg Hall Greg Center
has been kicking around now for a long
long time so it's
many people's pet projects in that
particular context of a game I can't
emphasize enough how important it is
that we'd get that facility back into
public use as quickly as at all possible
so all of these projects I think are
really with the stand up to scrutiny and
I think they should be now put forward
as as soon as possible and let's get
them moving as quickly as we can thank
you you know we have to approve the
money first so far right Casa Jefferson
Thank You chair I just wanted to pick up
on the upgrade and modernization of CCTV
CCTV was first installed in 1997 it's
reaching the end of its life it needs
upgrading and the software that
underpins it my governor is no longer
supported so this actually needs we knew
it needs investing in if we also
maintain the service and there is no
doubt about it it's seen as important by
the public it's strongly supported by
the police and it's not only dealing
with criminality and anti-social
behavior but it's also extremely
important in looking at missing persons
so there are a whole raft of reasons and
why I think this really does leave
investing in now if we leave it there's
a chance of so this could deteriorate
significantly right councilor house
thank you very much mr. chairman this
item was discussed at the last overview
and scrutiny committing at committee
meeting as an item that was coming up
and some of the points that we discussed
were covered by council moss in
particular what concerned us were two
things we didn't feel that we've got
enough information about the Evergreen
business fund and we would also have
been looking for more information on the
Ulster Greg Center which in fact you've
given us this afternoon we were however
and thanks very much to councillor
Jefferson for picking up on this point
we were pleased about
Great Moderation of modernization of
CCTV because this does add a valuable
tool to the police in the not only the
prevention but the detection of crime so
we were extremely pleased to see that
and also I suppose that overview and
scrutiny committee would perhaps
sometimes like to see these things
before they got to paper because we're
not just a scrutiny committee we can
help with overview as well so we're just
putting forward the possibility that we
might be able to help in some cases
right mr. Buckland referred to a meeting
that we have planned with a firm called
bone yes we're meeting with them next
Monday
of course that's just to explore the
possibilities if there were any
opportunities that we would need to
parameter tender we would we would
absolutely do that so I just want to
make sure it's a thirst is a
fact-finding discussion that we're
having with them references always also
been made by cast remote about the need
for business cases now in relation to
the nine spending areas that we have
under fers we've actually identified on
paragraph 112 that we need further
business cases for six of those nine and
I think the point there's no excuse yet
they've been made in relation to the
CCTV equipment that we've got an
identified spending need in that
particular area to modernize equipment
now and therefore that was felt that a
business case wasn't required for that
purpose it is part of our ongoing
services provision and therefore we
would not comport with that the other
two items are relatively modest sums
thirteen sixty five thousand so I just
want to make the differentiation why I
love the schemes included and also very
Center there will be further reports to
the cabinet what's being asked for at
this point is a budgetary provision for
cap on council for these particular
schemes subject to business cases from
Canada okay
right counts the kettle again briefly
that comes Shem and I notice as a ward
member from the southeast or the east of
the area that we've got studly named
also named Henry Nardin CCTV in
Stratford seems to be a paucity of names
such as southern or even bishops
hitching ttan a growing settlement
therefore can I be reassured that the
CCT coverage is being delivered across
the district or enhanced across the
district or replaced across the district
and that the focus of this isn't merely
in Stratford and secondly but you know
if we are going to enhance things like
the suddenly Leisure Centre that we've
got equal provision fund funding for
this for this what someone called where
do we look at southern labor center to
ensure that that is equally to give
residents in East that sort of support
right before I bring the portfolio
holder in I must protest that councillor
kettles protests there because in the
time that I've been here
the CCTV equipment has been installed
not just in Stratford but also in South
amend Lee in Ulster right in ships in'
and indeed a number of other rural
locations so i bount a missed a few out
and councillor jefferson will
effectively correct me Tony Thank You
chair I have to say there is CCTV in in
Southam and this is to cover updating
and renewing across the district which
is really important there is I think
twice a year a meeting of
representatives from all the towns that
have CCTV here and the support from
those towns he's strong it may not
always have been
but certainly the last me dinner I
attended the support for the CCTV
service was extremely strong I'm not
sure about bishops itching ttan but I
suppose if there was a serious amount of
trouble there we could always manage to
install I'm sure for your benefit
councillor kettle I think a lot of
villages do have their own CCTV I know
we doing bishops in our software and
machinery has all got to be replaced but
whether there could be an opportunity
within this budget to expand or consider
whether some of those TV CCTV systems
that are currently in place in other
settlements could be linked in basically
to get the main problem is storage
currently we can review the images when
we do review the images whenever we have
a problem
but the storage of a hard disk somewhere
in the back of the sports pavilion is
not terribly good and it may be the same
case in a lot of other settlements as to
whether there may be a link in to Tony's
our personal server so that we could
store those images on a more secure
basis do we need to spy on what goes on
around the back of schools from there
yes okay castle endeavors though I think
to be very accountable can be removed a
very valid point I think this is
something we can actually look at and if
there are CCTV operations within
villages then it may well make sense at
this point in time to actually integrate
them into the overall system and
integrate it into the control room so I
think that's a very valid point and I
think it's something that I am more than
happy to ensure is looked at councillor
moss
is right there's an imbalance
geographically within this I accept also
the point that councilor Cargill is
making that some of these are not to be
revenue generators and business case
will therefore be fairly brief exercise
of costings but what does surprise me
still chairman is that we're trying to
allocate sums of money to each of these
projects I could well understand
spending two and a half million
allocating that for various project but
I do believe it's quite possible other
councillors may come forward with things
which if properly considered will rank
more highly than the ones we've got
listed here equally mr. Buckland says
six of these we've still to develop
business cases for the business case may
promote with something that bears no
resemblance to these sums of money so
could we have an assurance chairman from
yourself in the portfolio holder that
this two and a half million necessary
will be moved around between categories
of items to give more flexibility rather
than pen exact amounts to nine projects
none of which we've really yet looked at
in detail an interesting proposal
councillor Moss because when as I said
to councilor Cargill early we can't do
anything unless we've got some money
here marked so there has to be the first
requisite and what will happen is if
this proposal or one that's amended by
some of your schemes effectively gets
supported of full council on the 24th
right these amounts won't necessarily go
into a single pot because you've got
different services that are responsible
for different functions and respond you
know so you've got CCTV which we've been
talking about which come under mr.
Grafton
you've got the broadband which will come
under mr. platts
right you've got the Gregg Center which
will come under mr. perks and as such
those monies will all go into their
particular departmental capital budgets
now we do have facilities and provisions
for moving money around absolutely the
point that the council will expand the
budget framework by 2.5 million in the
vironment walls which were in place
exist maybe will still be okay so
therefore the point is we still get the
money approved in the first place right
I think we've probably had a good debate
on this now and we've looked at issues
whether their portfolio holders pet
projects or whether or not they're
things that we consider are in the
corporate good and the cabinet is
responsible for looking at things
corporately it has to look at things
from a district wide basis and obviously
bishops itching tonie's been completely
forgotten about in whatever we're
proposing but we've had a reminder not
to neglect it this afternoon so
consequently we now have a situation
whereby we need council to make a
decision on this and there'll be an
opportunity to debate all these things
again or and any other extra zip that
you wish to do so
and I can assure you that the council
Chairman would effectively encourage a
sensible debate on it but this report
looks at the overall picture it looks at
the opportunities it looks for the scope
of spending and we don't have limitless
funds when we first started discussing
this we were looking at a slightly
smaller figure than we're now asking you
to approve but we're thinking that that
is possible within the medium term
financial plan so I'm going to ask
members to take the recommendation to
Council on page 15 the priorities are
supported 2.5 for 5 million BM
from the council's general fund reserves
is that agreed with that amendment on
the wireless we sort of skipped over
them and it's quite important to me in
table two you want wireless broadband
into the rural broadband are we agree
with that are we happy with that right I
take it that's all agreed next item item
six 2017 air quality annual status
report counselor brain mr. perks that
currently offered to introduce this item
for me thank you thank you can stir
brain suffering with his voice I'll read
out his introduction for him the report
we are considering here today provides
response to the notice of motion that
was submitted earlier this year and
respected by our air quality management
areas the motion was referred to the
councilors regulatory and overview and
scrutiny committees for consideration
and they've written to the matter in
some detail and their responses to the
detail questions raised within the
motion are included in the report that
you have before you today
it's sometimes since this motion was
initially raised and during this time
the work has continued and the
environmental health team have reviewed
the location of a number of the
monitoring tubes they've continued to
continue to monitor air quality they're
currently working with our planning
policy team and the regional
environmental health body to produce
guidance that will help improve air
quality within the district your us
today to endorse the responses to the
questions raised in the notices of
motion that the regulatory committee has
agreed and support the ongoing work
relating to improving air quality of in
the district fine
any particular debate counselor frankly
personally I'm not specifically aware of
it the Regional Health Gathering which
is actually through the chair yes I
completely agree with you cats too
fragile those no indication we would
seek to stop monitoring air quality in
areas where there's any risk what we
might look to do is to use the resource
sort of more prudently in areas where
there is being constantly levels well
below we might look to move monitoring
into areas which are at higher risk as
developments progressive in the district
or as issues become we become more aware
of issues so we will be looking to
rationalize rather than remove I think
may I just say that is very much the
response I'm hoping for and an assurance
that
other places where residents which I'm
sure I'm also grateful chairman the
reassurance the mr. percolo you gave me
that there'd be no question of canceling
the air quality management area in
Stratford without the Matic coming to
full council that's appreciated one
final point chairman the report does say
that in 2017 I wonder if we could be
told when the report on our council area
for the year 2017 we'll have to ask mr.
perks that question I've rather wished
you wouldn't have asked me that once I'm
quite sure it is I'm afraid but I will
find out and report back to you hmm
right I think in general terms I have
not discouraged you from having a debate
today our job as cabinet is to consider
the motion because it was referred to us
but we have to report back to full
council so there'll be an opportunity at
full council to debate this
unfortunately at full council is
unlikely that we'll have the opportunity
to pick on mr. perks his brains to
actually help us in our debate so you've
got an opportunity to do that this
afternoon
because I am at liberty to allowed to
speak today and normally would have
officer speaking at a cabinet but
effectively the council procedure rules
limit the speaking to members so
consequently if you want to ask a
technical question even if he has to
take it away and get an answer for you
do that at this afternoon
otherwise I'm seeing that it's quite
clear we have a report from the scrutiny
committee and the scrutiny committee
considered the recommendations from the
regulatory committee were endorsed and
those are effectively listed on page 28
and 29 because there are four questions
and four answers to go with it so I
think what we are being asked to do is
say our response to that motion is
embodied within those four questions and
answers and we'll send those back to the
council but there is an additional one
that has come from the scrutiny
committee which I'm fully happy to
support that the council it says
prepared in past tense I think it means
don't think the D should be there the
council prepare a detailed action plan
so clearly we need an action plan in
order to be able to not just monitor air
quality but take control of it so that
we don't get undesirable byproducts
through being casual about it you can
kind of say as proposal in secondary of
the motion I think we are pleased with
the recommendations that come forward
and sort this with the provider of the
addition okay mr. Perkis has given us
and perhaps you might take the
opportunity applicants
chairman since mr. perks can't speak to
tell us when the the next report will be
available right well I think he's heard
that question so I'm expecting him to
come up with an answer so the
recommendations on page 27 that those
are for questions and answers that I
referred to are sent to Council as our
response or the cabinet's response and
that we do prepare an action plan for
managing the process and the outcomes
from that is that agreed agreed thank
you next item item seven notice of
motion housing mix now this is an
interesting one because talking to the
local press about this
it was quite timely we've done an awful
lot of work on this not just because of
the motion that was put forward but
because it was in the work program of
the leaders policy advisory group now
what does the leaders policy advisory
group have to do well it has to remind
itself but in the core strategy the
question of how we implement housing mix
will be covered by a development
requirements SPD that's in the core
strategy quite clear and unchallenged
and therefore we have to produce a
development requirements SPD and we're
quite close to being a position to do
that a lot of the groundwork has been
done and the groundwork includes a set
of recommendations but developers if
they want to deviate from CS 19 which is
the housing mix there's a long list of
bullet points in paragraph 1.7 page 34
and any developer that wants us to
deviate or consider deviating I'm not
suggest that we should be 2lakhs about
this at all
we need that housing mix because it
provides a reasonable quantity of larger
houses for developers to sell but also
if we increase the number of four
bedroom and five bedroom houses by
definition we must reduce the quantity
of two and three-bedroom houses that we
provide those houses of that size are
vitally important if we are going to
play our part in the government scheme
to make certain that there is housing
available for first-time buyers and
people that want to get on the housing
ladder so if we deprive the public
through planning permissions of actually
receiving those number of new houses on
the market that they could buy if
they're a first-time buyer then we are
actually doing nobody any service at all
therefore our fully supports as
maintaining the housing mix in the core
strategy as far as possible or as much
as possible so we have a situation this
the developers are still are going to
come to us and say we think we ought to
be allowed to build more larger
quantities they must actually put up a
plea and the plea means they have to
address all these bullet points that are
in 1-7 now we haven't had to do any
extra work recently because that work
was already done by L peg many many
weeks ago
it certainly wasn't done because the
Town Council decided that they would
also complain about the housing mix of
properties that got approved planning
permission and they had every right to
do so however what I said to the press
was that the Town Council need to expect
brownie points on this because we've
done it today but I said that to mr.
luck I thought it would be an
off-the-record comment but he printed it
so anyway so consequently I'm on record
now so
that at least he didn't ask me the
question the observer gave all the glory
to the town council and didn't even
consult us so consequently I've had an
agreement to actually talk to the
observer after this has been this
motions been to council in a fortnight's
time and see if we can get a different
angle on it because I think we are
serious about the contents of our core
strategy and the decisions of course -
very it will be made by the planning
committees and they will have to sort of
judge and weigh things up and the
chairman of one of the planning
committee is gradually maneuvering
ourselves himself into position
presumably is going to protest about
this what I'm saying but however that is
the reality planning permission is
granted by the planning committees and
effectively they have to follow that
through so consequently what I'm saying
is that we actually give this bullet
point of this which is the same that
it's going to appear in the development
requirements SPD that document is
currently out for consultation and it's
out for consultation till the 20th
foolishly last week I asked mr. Kerr
fir'd if he could actually do a quick
job on the consultation responses and
feed in some views from whoever's
responded by the council meeting on the
24th very politely but also very firmly
he said no because on the grounds of the
effectively most of the consultation
responses he said will come in after
lunch on the final day of the
consultation and they won't have had
time to assess or appraise them in any
way or shape or form so although he's
quitting all over his face and me
telling you this it is a conversation we
had and effectively I'm not so going to
complain about it but however I thought
it was worth asking councilor Jefferson
Thank You chair how's the town council
motion has been raised can I declare the
time a member of Stratford 10 council
yes applause all right okay I saw your
hand before I saw his councillor riches
shall we stop messing about and you so I
support the evidence has come back on
this I guess I've got a question because
there seems to be this issue with the
housing mix where we get trumped by that
horrific viability issue that we've had
forced upon us through the MPP F it's
not a far week the attends to get full
service from central government and my
last understanding was that there was
they were due to the revisions to the
MPP F yes it could well change the way
that that viability discussion rolls out
further empowering our own core strategy
in CS 19 I mean that this is planning
policy but we do get trumped when it
comes to cash and then the planning
inspector would give us a bump on it so
I guess the question is possibly for
John when do we expect the revisions to
the MPP F to start to roll out when do
we get a stronger a stronger weapon when
it comes to to imposing these well the
MPP F consultation is out we haven't got
to the deadline and I can't remember in
the consultation period closes but we
will respond to it and can I remind you
of what I've said before mr. Webb and I
were at a conference or meeting at the
LGA just before Christmas when we had
the chairman of the co G Select
Committee in Parliament they're
addressing us and he said he would look
themselves to modify the viability
issues and tighten up on developers
ability to exploit it through changes to
the NPP f now we're not there yet
because clearly the consultation periods
got too close the government will then
publish its response
to the consultation it'll then go
through to the Select Committee and the
government still have got to publish the
actual revised MP PF and whatever is
going to say and we haven't got a clue
when that would happen I can always
remember being at the LGA when Eric
Pickles was there a minister and he was
pressed for dates and the best you could
get out of him it's imminent even the
minister didn't know when his officials
were going to publish things so
consequently we have a situation there
where I can't give you I can't tell you
when the date will be it will be in due
course when we've gone through all the
rigmarole on the performance of doing
whatever the government needs to do to
actually amend the NDP f counselor most
human I think the government's approach
to viability it's more conservative
fordable housing I could be wrong and
this is particularly our concern here is
about housing mix and can I say chairman
I found myself almost complete agree
your introductory remarks this is a
major problem an increasingly serious
problem and I'm delighted that in the
past couple of weeks both west and east
planning committees have both rejected
applications on the grounds that housing
did not comply with our core strategy
chairman my questions if I may we as you
quite rightly say have a list of bullet
points here them are being consulted on
for the planning development
requirements SPD which as you say will
take some time before it's finalized
could I ask Germany are the planning
committees entitled to take that into
account as emerging guidance on policy
from today for example does it apply to
shorter each straightaway or do we
actually have to wait until the SPD is
in place before anybody can take it
these guys
these new checks into account
second point chairman when people when
the developers have been flawed
explanations as to why they can't beat
the lake there and housing mix can we
have an assurance that what they say
will always be in the public domain
thank you well I can't govern who says
what in the public domain and who says
it in private but of course don't forget
the decisions are being made of planning
committees playing committees be in the
public domain they can the Chairman can
actually draw people into confidential
session but it happens very rarely as
you all know now the other thing then is
of the present time all these bullet
points are in a document which is out
for consultation the draft development
requirements SPD and I would hope that
planning committees will be advised by
their officers to actually give some
weight to that we have had a case
actually at a couple occasion in my ward
where as effectively I was told and it
was confirmed by Mason ash that the
effectively decisions on route to
getting an SPD did carry some weight
so therefore we have got an established
precedent for that you know I'm afraid
as board member I had to challenge the
amount of weight they've given but
that's another story who won't reinvent
that here but the issue was that so
therefore emerging planning guidance
does carry some weight and if it crops
up in a report to the planning committee
that report should refer to this
emerging planning guidance I would have
expected it so because as I say it's
been out since the beginning of March so
any report the ghost of committee
shouldn't have the benefit of that
already council kettle
the proposal in the pack does refer to
section m4 of this which we discuss and
that the evidence that mr. careful put
forward here is quite clear for plus
beds delivered since twenty and twenty
eleven twenty seven percent against a
maximum combined mix on seventeen
percent that has been paid for by an
under deliver II of one two and three
bed houses tears Jones words as can be
seen of the homes built to date there is
a significant over provision of larger
four plus bed homes and under provision
all other size of dwellings most notably
two and three bed hose what I've got
which report doesn't include is the
feedback from a report prepared for
Stratford in relation to an East error
and application which actually submitted
a proposal and one of those there is
that Stratford as the under occupancy of
eighty point six in saptrishi compared
to seventy six point three in
Warwickshire and one point six
overcrowding compared to two point four
in Warwickshire as a whole that shows
that Stratford has got less of a demand
in the rest of Warwickshire as a
district therefore I think that going
back to the report in paragraph one
point four it says case officers will
rely on the council stated policy as the
basis for these discussions and I'm
slightly concerned about that Ward
wording that the basis of these
discussions because I would be more
comfortable if cabinet would actually
accept that the unnecessary of
exceptional circumstances that the call
strategy bans
and I've now lost it which go up to 17%
I think from a collection for the mix
should be adhered to not formed as the
basis yes if there are exceptional
circumstances then it could be
reasonable
to vary from that but if there are not
exceptional circumstances given we've
already more than adequately provided
for class bedroom houses across the
district we do not have the luxury of
using the basis we should have it far
stronger and I'd like to see that change
put through mr. chairman and it's
interesting that both in my ward and an
application west which I've now counts
the most smokers remember the public the
planning committees both turned down
applications or amended in his case
applications where the housing mix was
cific significantly in a favor of four
plus way way way above that recommended
no wrinkle strategy so please can we
have a far stronger proposal say giving
advice to planning officers to give them
the weapons to turn around and say sorry
cabinet has reinforced and if we say 17%
mix for 4 plus houses that is a maximum
not a basis right well before our
bringing council fragile II I think
you're asking a little bit too much of
cabinet cabinet sense of the policy
right or Council sets the policy based
on a recommendation from cabinet that is
the limit of our involvement because the
law quite clearly divides the work that
council doe in two different sorts of
business and what cabinets can handle is
what's known as executive business
dealing with a planning application is
not an executive matter it is somewhat
crudely referred to as a non-executive
although we sometimes refer to that as a
regulatory issue therefore cabinet won't
necessarily full council can and you can
raise this when this goes to council
should you wish but effectively cabinet
effectively puts on place
recommendations to Council on policy and
I can assure you I would get all of us
fully endorsed sticking as close to this
housing mix as we can I can't see any
reason for it and as I say we have
pitched that housing mix based on
estimates research and an evidence base
and that evidence base is because of
what our local needs are and that we
should endeavor to actually deliver and
supply those local needs but effectively
I don't think we can dictate to planning
officers or planning committees just how
far they deviate they must use the
evidence before then in making their
decision councilor fragile II thank you
Jeff I just wanted to say I'm a town
councillor as well as a district
councillor and I think the debate at
Town Council was in support of the
neighbourhood plan because they've had a
consultation on local have or town
housing needs actually go in to say they
have an evidence base from which the
figures derive which are similar to the
the core strategy question I'd like to
ask is really how to what it is in the
merging neighborhood plan at the moment
but really that should be carrying
weight alongside and supporting the call
strategy and I think any information
that comes through and push that comes
through from any council level is
important in actually making sure this
housing mix is delivered as far as
possible I'm sure that's right we look
forward to seeing Sanford's neighborhood
plan I've been tipped off by mr. Kerr
food that we've been promised it soon
shortly and indeed I'm aware you can't
vary
unable to plan too far from what it says
in the core strategy because you need to
be compliant with it and I'm sure that
point is not lost in by the people who
are preparing Stratford's neighborhood
plan I mean it does have independent
consultation data support housing mix
right well we've had a long discussion
and debates about that hope I miss I'll
sew him up right counselor cargo Thank
You chairman so he could see me there
but okay right thank you very
interesting debate this particular one I
think most of my colleagues on planning
would have seen the trend for the the
viability studies that come from
developers over the last year or so I
raised it with John about a year ago and
saying do we have Leith and up-to-date
figures on the housing mix and we we
didn't have a I welcome this document
and I welcome the actual the emphasis it
puts on it but there are question did
two things I'm not playing devil's
advocate here but if the the the other
week we had last week we have the salt
prize come through on school Road now
that particular one was community led so
in other words they actually decided on
the housing because they wanted for
their for their community and it was
different to the core strategy and
that's the one that we are looking at we
will come back to us in the inland in
the not-too-distant future
so okay I come back to the one size does
not fit all in this particular case you
can't have it to say one that would suit
Stratford doesn't necessarily suit
somewhere else so I think the
flexibility we need to put in is
probably about right I should say I'm
just picking at the point where the
county kettle said they're about the
basis of in section one six it well not
six it does say that new considerations
which are any develop the seeking of
variation from the preferred mix will
need to satisfy so natural fact they
have to satisfy all those bullet points
and there's quite a number in there
some of them I'm not sure they can
actually be enforced easily but there
you go we will find that in time on
evidence of local market circumstances
I would suggest that we also need to put
a minimum time for them to come back and
say we've gone out to the market to
assess this because otherwise it could
say well we popped down the local estate
agent they said there was no demand
there for us proof so we need to put a
minimum times in those particular items
we've obviously discussed quite quite
significantly the amount of housing
bedrooms four or five bedrooms we are
making the assumption that developers
prefer those because they're easy to
build and make more profit may be true
but we also have to balance that need
against the smaller housing requires two
beds for example I'm not a great fan of
warm beds but they they do fit in the
right location so for example in in
Stratford it may be much much more
suitable here to have one bed but where
else in the countryside would you want
that in the rural communities probably
more two and three and positive four
beds so I just want to say that I just
bought this in principle I got a few
concerns about it I am actually raising
some issues through with with the SPD
but like I said it's not a one size fits
all we've got have some flexibility in
there and where counsel Carol said it
it's got to be you know solid antique I
can't deviate from it that wouldn't work
and that's obviously going to come back
to the committee at some point where we
won't make the decisions based upon the
evidence that comes forward thank you
chairman it wasn't specifically on what
council cargle it says okay but we've
given this a good debate and it's got to
go to Council so no doubt we'll have a
debate there when it gets there we're
going to have a busy amazing army so
recommendation in response to the notice
of motion is received I think what we
have to do is to recommend to cabinet
that we sorry to Council yeah that we
support the motion and the applicant
would be expected to include the
information evidence as part of an
adjuster vacation to vary as outlined in
1.7 is that what we're saying to Council
yes right is that agreed thank you item
8
traveler Neighborhood Development Plan
considering it's next door to
snitterfield it's a little bit thinner
but the issue is that clementines
neighborhood development plan is a
little bit at an earlier stage than the
severe one and we're at the stage where
the cabinet can handle things and what
we have to go through is they submit
their pre submissions consultation to us
we make some comments as a critical
friend before it goes off to the
external examiner and then comes back to
us into your course so consequently they
have got a neighborhood plan which we
have a copy of we have in our papers
today and appendix which is a commentary
on that plan appendix r1 on page 47 and
it refers to a number of things some of
which are typos some of which are far
more fundamental our job this afternoon
is to agree that the appendix represents
the appendix represents the comments
that we'd like to send to clabber dn't
for them to amend to their pre
submission consultation and then it will
comes back to us when the examiners had
his or her say any comments debate no so
can I have your agreement then about the
schedule of comments depend it's one
people alone has printed on page 43 so
curry right item nine not a notice of
motion
back cause this is a more recent one and
what we have to do is decide how we're
going to handle it not look at it in
some detail today well unless we decide
to do that but I'm suggesting very
effectively of the options which at the
top of page 58 we pick option B which is
to ask for an officer report to help us
debate and discuss things what do you do
looking's are guilty for counselor
kettle Wickham is Chum clawback clauses
in the commercial world which I have
worked have been known as earn outs and
we used or proposed on a very regular
basis in basic the sale of companies if
the company did well the owners got more
the company did badly that were sold the
company got the original owners got less
and they were very they were proposed as
a methodology to bridge a misalignment
between the vendors and the purchasers
expectations on price and in the private
equity market this was a great tool and
then as they began to get you proposed
and then used the vendors were normally
stitched up in a simple word because the
controller of the performance after the
deal was the purchaser he had control
over pricing he had control over
management charges had control over this
he had control over that control over
the other and at the end of the day what
was seen as a wonderful opportunity is
bridging actually was a palliative cure
that had no benefit whatsoever so the
vendor
who at the end of the day got a lower
price than you might expect when we see
clawback clauses to resolve the
difference between the expected
performance of development site and the
outcome guess who's in control the
developer I see exactly the same
problems in this proposal that we I have
personally seen professionally seen in
the private equity market and I would
recommend strongly that yes it should be
considered considered by a working group
within the overview and scrutiny
committee because currently there are
two members who have experience of that
on the overview and scrutiny committee
and that that should be the route we
should go forward
clearly with office or input at the same
time okay not that much detail today but
we'll know what you've said
councillor Rich's I'm keen to do this
noted what councillor Cutler's just said
we can't make any decision on this at
all in the absence of officer feedback
and legal advice
we just need to crack on and get that
feedback before we make any decisions
council boss
Thank You Gemma nyla I agree with cancer
kettle these things to be gained I would
say had this been introduced in March
2000 the first theme when we first put
it forward I think the housing market
over the past five years has moved in
such a way this council would never been
receiving money from such clauses but of
course this is all open activate by
bondage and we couldn't offer lot of
these housing things which are really
related in some way rather than create
extra work I wonder if this committee
right
it's interesting you should say that
because you always sleep well up on this
I'm not sure that members of the cabinet
could actually make a firm decision
without the benefit of an officer report
and that's what was suggested over here
by counsel issues and I will endorse
that so I think we don't try and
effectively resolve this issue this
afternoon we seek an officer report it
has to come to us for us for a
methodology as to how to deal with it so
I'm going to suggest therefore that I
will second counselor Rich's proposal to
do option B and we'll come back to our
cell about a meeting soon so agreed
thank you right now I'm moving on the
only other item item 10 is an on block
item nobody's asked to bring that out so
I'll ask you to actually note that
particular reports which they've agreed
and then we finally come on to urgent
business mr. Webb
right I've just been reminded um every
May there's a duty on the leader to
provide a statement to council on the
contents and whoever's in the cabinet
and various rules about delegations the
one I did last May are you might think
you have months later it's very much out
of date but I've been doing some work
with mr. Grafton particularly he says he
doesn't want to load a credit for this
but I spoke to him earlier but the
effectively he's simply doing his job
but I will credit him with a lot of help
that statement has been revised and such
he's had to be revised for two or three
reasons one is I've had a couple of
changes in cabinet counselor Jefferson's
been brought in and counselor Lawtons
been brought in so he needed updating
for that and also the representation on
the local enterprise partnership is now
in the hands of councillor riches
instead of me so we've had to update it
for that reason but also we've had a
pretty thorough look at officer
delegations and I think we've involved
that in recent weeks mr. Webber mr.
Buckland have both involved in it what
it should say and I think we have now a
statement that all four of us are happy
with and so that will be published as an
amendment to last May's document and we
will deal with next May's document when
we get to the annual meeting right so
but that's as far as I just wanted to
make certain that members were not
surprised by it I I had hoped at one
time to have this ready before Christmas
but sadly it didn't happen and work out
that way it has been quite an extensive
exercise to look at some of the detail
that goes in but ours looks a bit more
substantial and a bit like many other
councils you really want to be a geek
one afternoon when it's raining take a
look through the various councils at all
everybody produces one and compare
okay thank you for reminding me mr.
Weber urgent business
I had no action business chairman right
okay that right I can close the meeting
at twenty past three thank you